let's bring into breaking news we've had
in within the last hour this is
concerning the prince of wales a raw
source saying that prince charles would
never again
handle large cash donations for his
charities now this news
comes after a story that run in ran in
the sunday times which said that prince
charles personally accepted donations
for his charities some of them
reportedly in a suitcase from a former
qatari prime minister um
let's get a bit more context to this
scar skies correspondence uh our role
correspondent rihanna mills joins us now
uh yeah a lot of our viewers will
remember this story rhiannon bag stuffed
with cash being given to the prince of
wales
yeah a really difficult read for the
palace over the weekend splashed all
over the front of
one of the newspapers suggesting that
the prince of wales between
2011 and 2015 had accepted around 3
million euros from the former qatari
prime minister but what's been unusual
today is that senior palace aide has in
more detail addressed
those claims and that senior palace
source in essence has said this would
not happen again i'll read you what
exactly they said and it said there have
been many reports and it was passed
immediately to his charities and it was
his charities who decided to accept the
money that is a decision for them and
they did so and they confirmed it all
followed the right processes the
auditors looked at it he went on to say
that the prince of wales operates on
advice situations context change over
the years
adding that for more than half a decade
with the situation as it has evolved
this has not happened and would not
happen again that is then and this is
now now in terms of where that money
went it went to the prince of wales's
charitable fund the palisade today also
keen to stress that at the moment the
charities commission are not
investigating this story the charities
watchdog did say on monday that they are
in essence looking at what they need to
investigate but when you speak to those
who know everything about charity
regulation it's not illegal for
charities to
accept cash and certainly there's no
suggestion that there was any illegal
wrongdoing when it comes to this
situation the problem is it is very
difficult when it comes to matters about
the prince's judgment and certainly i
think the aide addressed that saying
that he takes advice but in terms of how
it looks for him it doesn't necessarily
look good especially at a time when we
know that the queen in particular is
really relying relying on him to step up
and take over many responsibilities and
really trying to shape in our
consciousness
him as a future king earlier he was
asked
about the charity issue and uh he
refused to comment as he's currently up
in scotland helping out the queen with
royal week
is it appropriate to accept millions of
packs for your charities sir
yeah so hardly surprising the usual
thing you ask a member of the royal
family a pertinent question and they
simply walk on by but i think for the
palace themselves they do feel that
ultimately they did want a senior aide
today to address those issues and hope
to in some ways
shut this down but it isn't easy
another difficult topic for the royal
family to address when we know that at
the moment there is so much focus on the
queen needing so much support from her
family